rush limbaugh sets off fireworks when he
suggests secession might be inevitable
106 house republicans backs texas's
election
2020 lawsuit and the media finally pay
attention to hunter biden i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
this show is sponsored by expressvpn
stop putting your online data at risk
get protected at expressvpn.com
we'll get to all of the news in just one
moment first let us talk about
the best holiday gift you can buy i'm
talking about the deluxe grillers
assortment
from omaha steak so i know that omaha
steaks are good because i'm special that
means they sent me a kosher steak like a
year ago year and a half ago
and let me tell you listen this thing is
just tender it is fork tender i mean it
is juicy it is delicious it is perfectly
it is perfectly aged and that is all
omaha steaks does is they make
the great meat and a bunch of other
great stuff as well here is exactly what
you're gonna get in that deluxe
griller's assortment
four six ounce top sirloins eight
boneless chicken breasts four omaha
steaks burgers eight gourmet jumbo
franks eight individually scalloped
potatoes
eight caramel apple tartlets and one jar
of signature seasoning
omaha steaks isn't just steak it is a
guaranteed fantastic gift a safe way to
share the joy of the season remember
when you order that deluxe griller's
assortment you also get four free omaha
steaks burgers and a free digital meat
thermometer with my code shapiro at
omahasteaks.com i mean that is like the
deal of the century right there
all of that delicious food and you are
getting it at discount
because omahastakes.com code shapiro
brings you magical magical things go to
omahasteaks.com
type shapiro in that search bar shop the
best gourmet gifts of the season again i
can attest to the taste of that steak
because they made me the only kosher one
go check them out right now omaha
steaks.com type shapiro in that search
bar and check out their deluxe grillers
assortment alrighty so the world of
commentary exploded yesterday
why well because rush limbaugh on his
show was talking about the fact we have
a massive culture gap in the country now
this is obviously obviously true it is
obviously true that there is a massive
culture gap between the left
and the right it is also obviously true
that there are many members of the
radical left who have such
a bizarre vision of the united states
that it is mutually exclusive with
traditional visions of how the united
states is supposed to work
and if you have a country where people
have fundamentally different conceptions
of words like freedom and justice where
you have
completely different notions of what
constitutes virtue and vice
it's gonna be very difficult for those
people to live together the only way
that you can have people live together
who disagree about these sorts of things
is to basically say that the government
should not be cramming down its
particular vision
on anybody that the government should be
small right this was one of the things
that the founders knew well they
realized that there were many states
the states lived differently people in
the localities then those states live
differently
and therefore an overarching very
powerful federal government would
actually be more likely to fracture than
the opposite they knew this because this
is exactly what had happened with great
britain because great britain had
basically said we're going to rule from
above
and the american colonies had said we
live a different lifestyle we are
a thou we're thousands of miles away
from you and we don't even know about
your decisions
and we don't have representation so
we're out and so the founders knew this
the founders recognized
that in a world where people have vast
disagreements the only way that you're
going to get them to agree to remain in
union with one another
is if you do not cram down too many
things upon them
the founders also recognized that there
had to be certain baseline levels of
agreement
on things like virtue and vice and this
is why john adams famously suggested
that the constitution of the united
states assumed a population
that lived within certain moral bounds
and certain moral structures because he
said
if you have a non-virtuous people it
will rush right through the
constitutional boundaries
like a whale through the chords of a net
and so all of this has been long agreed
upon there's nothing controversial about
the idea that if we have nothing in
common things are sort of going to fall
apart this is something that rush
limbaugh
mentioned yesterday and until five
seconds ago the media would have agreed
until five seconds ago the meteor said
look at this this terrible terrible
country with
donald trump as the head of it can we
live
in peace and harmony with these people
no we can't live in peace and harmony
with these people
we we're gonna have to break apart i
mean this whole thing is just falling
apart then they believe that joe biden
was elected and suddenly it's unity time
again and this is what the media
always do they suggest that unity is
only to be had when they when their
perspective is dominant
when they win then we're supposed to be
unified when they lose then we are
supposed to
fall apart now there are many of us who
are pointing out you know during the
first term of trump that this thing was
falling apart regardless of whether
republicans or democrats are running the
show because their fundamental
disagreements in the united states over
what the united states represents
ought to represent what our vision ought
to be for the future is it a division of
liberty or as a division of
forced equality from the top down
so rush mentions this yesterday and of
course the world sets a flame because
the idea is
that russia is very bad for saying this
now they do this every time
an election is over and a democrat
appears to have won and back in 2008
after barack obama won rush said he
hoped that obama failed
he didn't mean that he hoped that barack
obama tried to do good things and failed
he said what he meant was it was very
obvious what he meant at the time he
meant
that he hoped that barack obama's
progressive agenda was a failure because
he did not want to see that progressive
agenda enacted
on the united states right it was very
obvious what he was saying the media
decided to go nuts anyway well
you know eight four what is it 12 years
later
12 years later rush limbaugh says
something fairly similar here which is
the country seems to be falling apart
that is perfectly obvious here was rush
yesterday i actually think that we're
trending
toward secession
i know that there is a sizable
and growing sentiment for people who
believe that that is where we're headed
whether we want to
or not whether we want to go there or
not
i myself haven't haven't uh haven't made
up my minds i still haven't
given up the idea that we are the
majority and that all we have to do is
find a way
to unite and win yes the media went
crazy over this because
how dare rush limbaugh in a time of
glorious democratic victory
suggests that the country is kind of
falling apart well the problem is that
one half the media was doing that
and meanwhile half the left is like yeah
you know what you're right we should go
our separate ways
so amy siskind who is a liberal
commentator
obviously she tweeted out a graphic from
circ about 2004
when members of the left were very very
angry about
george w bush winning reelection and
what this graphic was is it showed
alaska in red
and most of the midwest in red with the
exception of like illinois and michigan
and i believe wisconsin there uh and uh
and virtually all of the rest
of the all of the rest of the country is
in red it's like the northeast
and the west coast and the and the
midwestern states that voted for john
kerry and then the rest of the country
is read and the suggestion was that all
of the blue states would join with
canada
and all of the red states would become
quote unquote jesus land it would be the
united states of canada
and jesus land right that was that was
the ridiculous suggestion that was being
put forth
by folks on the left as early as 2004
which is that these
differences are irreconcilable now i got
to tell you the differences of 2004
look pasty in comparison to the
differences that we
currently hold in the united states we
have a huge percentage of the population
in the country that apparently believes
that the country is systemically racist
and unfixably so that believe that
government can solve all of your
problems from
the top down all that is required is
sufficient willpower to do so and that
believe the constitution ought to be
put completely aside in order to make
all this happen
but to pretend that it is not the left's
fevered hatred for folks on the right
that has really driven so much of the
sort of secession talk
is to ignore who is in control of the
institutions of culture
we know who's in control of the
institutions of culture we know who's in
control in hollywood
we know that in hollywood it is people
on the left who are in control and they
wish to purvey a particular view of the
world
and they wish for you to buy this
particular view of the world and if you
do not then you are
going to be castigated in hollywood as a
backward redneck
we know that the folks who are in charge
of the media have one particular view
of themselves and their own viewpoint
and they believe they are objectively
right and if you disagree with them you
are objectively wrong
and therefore you ought to be cast out
of the bounds of polite society
the folks in the university system have
created their own little religion of
wokism
where you cannot work you cannot work
unless you believe in the fundamental
tenets of quote unquote social justice
warrior
nonsense the social justice movement is
predicated on a certain level of
post-modernist
philosophy that suggests there is no
such thing as objective truth or
objective right
but there is such a thing as objective
identity and we can base
our viewpoint on whether your objective
identity meaning your race or your
ethnicity or your sexuality
whether these things are victimized in
the united states and if you don't abide
by that particular viewpoint
well then you'll be thrown out of the
academy the institutions are controlled
by the left
the only way that the right has fought
back really has been in the world of
politics winning the occasional vote
winning the house in 2010 winning the
senate in 2014 winning the presidency in
2016.
right so occasionally the right fights
back but they don't fight back in the
realm of culture and as long as the
culture continues to polarize
so long as you turn on the tv and all
you get is one side of the political
political aisle railing at you day in
and day out
it's going to feel more and more as
though we're going to have to pull apart
the founders knew this this is nothing
new and people today know it so to
pretend
that we would have unity but for people
like rush limbaugh or people on the
right
is to really suggest that we would have
unity if you would just agree with us
now listen i don't think folks on the
left have to agree with me in order for
us to have a baseline level of unity so
we can move forward as a country i think
we can disagree on tax rates we can
fight over tax rates
i think we can disagree on certain
social issues and i think that that's
totally within the bounds of us still
being the american family
i think once you get to the point where
you believe the constitution ought to be
overthrown in favor of an administrative
state
ruled from above by unelected officials
who can interfere in every area of
individual rights
well now you're talking about something
different and to
sort of gloss over these philosophical
differences simply because you think joe
biden was elected
demonstrates the agenda of so many in
the media making an issue over what rush
said
yesterday in a second we'll get to
barack obama who again has been
pasting over these issues barack obama
is a is a seminal figure in the tearing
a part of the country
and if you want to watch gaslighting in
real time all you have to do is watch
barack obama's book tour because the
media have declared that he is in fact a
unifying figure again
any time a democrat wins according to
the media that means he's a unifying
figure any time a republican wins that
means the country is on the brink of
falling apart
for me the question is not who wins and
who loses elections the question is what
values are being promulgated
and how much do those values cast an
entire other side of the political aisle
out of the family of americans wish
everybody else out into the cornfield
we'll get to this in one second first
let's talk about something unbelievably
delicious are you a waffle person i am a
waffle person
i love waffles my kids love waffles
that's why i could not have been more
excited to bring on board the presto
stuffler stuffed waffle maker i'm
talking about
using a waffle maker for pretty much
everything we were talking sweet we're
talking savory you can make
waffles they're stuffed right so what
you do is you take the waffle
batter you pour it in then you put in
your stuffing then you put on more
waffle batter
and then you just close the machine
after it bakes a little bit you flip it
over it is unbelievably delicious we are
talking about putting fruits chocolate
cheesecake pie fillings nuts candy
inside your waffle or you can do it the
savory style chicken meat fish eggs
veggies right you could do this for keto
you could do it for gluten-free
right the the presto stuffer stuffed
waffle maker this thing is a godsend my
kids
absolutely love the food that we create
with it and deciding what's put inside
that waffle can be great fun
honestly my kids help us make the
waffles they decide what we want to use
for the filling and then we all get
together around
the counter and we put it together
ourselves go to www.stuffler.com
click the buy now and then the add to
cart button enter promo code ben to get
off that is stuffler.com promo code ben
after you add it to the cart and you get
off right now presto will provide dozens
of recipes and intriguing ideas for
batter and delicious stuffing again
treat your family with a stuffer for
hanukkah or christmas today it is a
great
great gift okay so barack obama
is a good indicator of where the media
stand on this whole should america fall
apart or not thing
so barack obama was great at one thing
and that was
lying about his actual philosophy so
what he did over and over and over is he
suggested that he liked the declaration
and he liked the constitution he just
didn't like anything about the
declaration in the constitution so he
would say things
like the declaration and constitution
signify who we are and then he would
immediately
cut back directly against the philosophy
of the declaration and the constitution
he would suggest that we're not black
americans and white americans we're all
americans and then he would
say that cambridge police officers acted
stupidly and that america
had racism in its dna and all the rest
of this sort of stuff so barack obama
was a very very divisive guy the media
continued to try to paint him as a
unifying figure because again
in the view of the media their view is
unifying any other view is divisive
so here is barack obama the other night
suggesting that the only reason
conservatives didn't love him was fox
news and rush limbaugh
i ended up getting enormous support in
these
pretty conservative rural largely white
communities
when i was a senator and that success
was repeated
when i ran for president in the first
race in iowa
you know by my second year in office i'm
not sure if i
could make that same connection because
now those same people
are filtering me through fox news and
rush limbaugh
and an entire conservative media
infrastructure
that was characterizing me in a way that
suggested i looked down on those folks
or
i had nothing in common with them
suggested you did look down on those
folks you said in 2008 that those folks
were bitter clingers who cling to god
and guns in xenophobia
suggested suggested no the big problem
is that conservative media was telling
the truth about barack obama and he
didn't like that
he liked it better when the media were
simply lying about barack obama and his
agenda
and when people talk about the
separation of the country you have to
understand that
the media acting as a filter for
democrats may help
the democrats win but it is not going to
unify the country in any serious way
it's just a way of pasting over serious
differences in the body politic
in order to achieve leftist victory that
is what the media are doing every single
day and by the way
the members of the media if they were
forced to the choice right now they
don't disagree with amy siskind they
look at red states with absolute scorn
they look at people who live in the red
states with absolute scorn
i went to law school with a lot of these
folks and they they they look at the
people who don't live in the big cities
and they look at them like they are
hicks and like they are rednecks and
they look at religious people in
particular as though they are stupid and
backward
they believe that their their sort of
secular world view ought to take
dominance
and predominant over religious world
views
they are some of the least tolerant
people i know and i've lived in
blue areas my entire life until the last
two months
literally my entire life i spent my
entire life in la and cambridge
massachusetts
and i can tell you that the the notion
that folks like barack obama do not look
down
on the on the so-called backward
rednecks in the middle of the country is
a lie they do look down on those people
they believe those people's values are
wrong this is why hillary clinton said
that people in america are going to have
to change their own religious values
in order to get in touch with the times
you think that doesn't pull apart the
country
it does pull apart the country okay now
this brings us to a larger point okay
and the larger point is this
if we wish to share a country we are
going to have to accept that there are
limits
to how much you get to interfere in
somebody else's life and what this means
is we ought to want to maintain a
principle which is that states ought not
interfere with other states
if you actually want to share a cup
maybe you don't want to share a country
maybe you want the country to fall apart
if you're on the left or maybe you're on
the right and you say okay well you know
what we're never going to win this
battle the battle's over so i give up so
fine let california go its own way let
new york go its own way let
massachusetts go its own way
and we're done here okay well if that's
your proposal then make a proposal but
if you believe that the country ought to
stick together or if you believe that
there is a silent majority that has been
forced into silence then one thing that
you should definitely want to make sure
of is that the folks in california and
new york don't get to run things in
texas
you want to make sure that the federal
government doesn't get to dictate
procedure
in terms of law with regard to texas or
mississippi or florida
or alabama or missouri or any other red
state
right you want to make sure that the
federal government actually makes room
for differences of opinion and this is
why it is very important
the world of law is not the same as the
world of culture or even the world
of sort of political thinking the world
of law establishes supposedly neutral
principles
once those principles have been
established they are very difficult to
disestablish
once you maximize power in the federal
government it is very difficult
to then dissolve power in the federal
government
so if you make a rule for example that
benefits people on the right at one time
at the level of the federal government
and then the left takes over the federal
government
then those same powers are going to be
available to people on the left and this
is something that
the right should have been aware of for
quite a while which is that if the right
bought into
the notion of bigger government in order
to promulgate their agenda the left
eventually takes over all those
instruments and then uses those
instruments against precisely the people
who wanted those instruments of power
put into place in the first place which
is why the right has traditionally been
a small government
party in the united states it's why
conservatives in the united states have
typically wanted the government out of
your business
it's why there is this sort of right
libertarian alliance
because the right in the united states
has understood that power is a
double-edged sword
right now you may be wielding it but
sooner or later somebody's going to grab
that sword from the other side they're
going to use it
against you i bring this up in the
context of this current texas supreme
court case
with regard to the 2020 election we're
gonna get to that in
just one second first let us talk about
your health so
getting in shape does not have to be
about losing a specific amount of weight
or a magic number on the scale it's
about building healthier habits and
feeling better about yourself
if you're fitting if fitting into that
favorite pair of jeans is a goal
great but there are a lot of reasons you
might want to be healthy like you know
not dying
living longer feeling more fit feeling
better well this is why
you have to make sure that you have
changed the habits in your life
a lot of diets fail because people think
they have to die for the next three
weeks then the diet is over and then you
just balloon back up
well noom will help you change your
habits on a day-to-day basis
noom is a habit-changing solution it
helps users learn to develop a new
relationship with food through
personalized courses
based in psychology noom teaches you why
you do the things you do and empowers
you with the tools you need to break bad
habits and replace them with better ones
noon doesn't tell you what to do and
what not to do it teaches you instead
how to look inside your own mind and
make better decisions for yourself
numa has one of the biggest most
accurate food databases available lets
you track meal habits
visualize portion sizes see calorie
density at a glance we're all strapped
for time new mass for just 10 minutes a
day for yourself
it's going to make you healthier it's
going to make you live longer because
you are healthier
this is why i love doom i've been using
numa myself you can tell i look very
svelte ever since the pandemic started
i've been a regular user of nume
my dad has been using nume as well sign
up for your trial today at noon
n-o-o-m.com
shapiro what do you have to lose aside
from the weight obviously visit noom.com
shapiro start that trial today that is
n-o-o-m-dot-com
shapiro okay so this brings us to this
texas supreme court case so texas
filed a case with the supreme court
they were trying to elevate the case
directly to the supreme court so the
constitution of the united states
provides
that the supreme court has direct
jurisdiction over controversies between
the states
so that means that it doesn't have to go
through the appellate procedure it goes
all the way up to the supreme court now
there is a debate
inside sort of original circles as to
whether the supreme court has to take up
that case
or whether the supreme court can reject
that case so really what is going up to
the supreme court right now
is a is a petition that the supreme
court will allow texas to bring this
case 17 other states have now signed on
to this case as well and the case
essentially amounts to texas and a bunch
of other red states 16 other red states
who are filing a lawsuit alleging that a
series of swing states
did not properly implement election law
inside their own borders
and therefore these 17 republican states
were disadvantaged in the electoral
college
and therefore the federal government
should step in and basically
rewrite all the election rules in these
particular states
that's the essence of the case and the
case makes a couple of claims
some of them are pretty flimsy legally
speaking for example they make a due
process claim suggesting that
due process substantive due process was
not taken essentially it's not fair
okay it's not fair it's not a legal
argument from an originalist perspective
it's not fair it's probably the worst
legal argument due process
was never meant to be quote unquote
substantive he's getting a little bit
arcane but substantive due process
is the basic idea under under the
constitution the basic idea is that
you cannot have your life liberty or
property removed without due process of
law now you would say to yourself due
process of law means
that there has to be a trial there must
be a trial by jury there has to be a law
in place it can't be an exposed facto
law it has to be a law that was in place
before you committed a crime
that's what due process means the
supreme court has crafted out of whole
cloth
this bizarre position that there is such
a thing as substantive due process
which if you think about that phrase for
a second makes no sense at all because
process and substance are not the same
thing they are opposites in fact there's
the substance and then there's the
process that you use
when you apply it to the substance right
a substance of a crime would be like
murder the process would be how you
adjudicate whether somebody has
committed murder or not
substantive due process is basically the
supreme court deciding
it's not fair so under the rubric of
substantive due process for example
the supreme court ruled that abortion
was a right so substantive duty process
has long been a bugaboo
in right-wing legal circles okay the
texas case relies on substantive due
process it makes the claim
that this is not fair because texas has
certain voting procedures and wisconsin
and pennsylvania violated their own
voting procedures and therefore that's
not fair
okay the reason that they're making that
claim of course is because
presumably they think that if the
electors in those various states are not
selected on the basis of the popular
vote in those states but by the state
legislatures
all of which are red then presumably
they will vote for trump and it will
shift the outcome of the election
now texas in the case doesn't say that
they say no no we're just concerned
about the state of the law here
but that seems rather dicey considering
that they didn't file this lawsuit until
the last five minutes
right if they're really that concerned
about the the state of play
in these various states with regard to
internal election law they theoretically
should have filed the lawsuit
long before they should have filed the
lawsuit when pennsylvania first redid
its mail-in balloting
initiative back in 2019 when a
republican legislature voted for
universal mail and balloting in 2019
before the pandemic
by the way and now there is there are
certainly
constitutional concerns on the state
constitutional level
in a large variety of these states
pennsylvania being the most obvious
in pennsylvania it is true that the
state constitution suggests that you
require a constitutional amendment in
order to radically
redo its voting laws the way that they
were done in 2019 like that's a legit
cause of action should that be elevated
to the supreme court typically the
supreme court says listen the federal
government has nothing to do
with internal deliberations with regard
to the creation
of of electors in a presidential
election
now what the texas case is claiming
is that the constitution of the united
states says that state legislatures
shall determine
the method of how electors are selected
so the state legislature could delegate
that to to the population the state
legislature could pass laws regarding
how people are to vote but it has to
come from the state legislature as the
claim that texas is making
now that claim is is fairly plausible on
its face the problem is that
in law you have to show a discrete
particular injury
okay you have to have what is called
standing so as i pointed out on the show
yesterday if producer colton gets hit by
a car i can't sue the guy who hit colton
with the car
on colton's behalf colton has to sue or
his family members have to sue
his heirs have to sue right i can't sue
because i don't have standing
okay so for texas to claim that it has
standing to challenge the internal laws
of a place like pennsylvania with regard
to its voting
it sounds good on the surface if you
want the election to change but it is
actually a very very bad legal principle
the reason it is a bad legal principle
is now you have opened the door this is
what i mean when i say
you do not want to appeal to the federal
government as your solution to all
problems
because once the federal government has
a particular power it's going to use it
against you
if let's say the supreme court were to
take up the texas challenge and say you
know what texas is right
texas was disadvantaged and affected
because wisconsin and pennsylvania
and and georgia their election laws were
were
poorly drawn and didn't actually prove
fraud by the way nothing in the texas
lawsuit actually alleges fraud or voter
irregularity actually happen it doesn't
actually allege that it just says that
the procedures used here
or violated the state constitutions
within those states okay
let's say that the supreme court went
along with that argument saying that
texas has standing to sue because texas
is part of the electoral college and
therefore
they are disadvantaged if pennsylvania
screws up its own voting
here is the problem with that the
problem with that is that you now end up
in the position
where any state could sue any other
state for a law implemented
in that second state as long as it had
an indirect effect on the first state
so for example california could sue
alabama on the basis of alabama's
abortion laws
by claiming that listen if people in
alabama can't get abortions you know
they're flying into california
in order to do that and that means that
alabama's abortion laws they affect
us and there's a right to privacy under
the constitution of the united states
under roe vs wade
and therefore california would have
standing to sue okay this is
not the world you want if you want the
country to hold together you do not want
there to have to be uniform laws across
the entire country
on a wide variety of issues in which
states can sue each other to provide for
that uniformity
then you do basically have a bare
majoritarian crime down
right effectuated by the supreme court
you actually don't want this
okay so you can think that some of the
claims made in the texas lawsuit are
legit
but they don't have standing to provide
them standing would be a constitutional
error of pretty extreme magnitude
and not only that even if they were
granted standing to
to judge that texas could change
election
law inside wisconsin or inside
pennsylvania
that is a that is a sword you do not
want to grant the supreme court that is
just not something you want the supreme
court involved in
right now there are majority of
republican appointees on that bench
okay in 10 15 years that probably is not
going to be the case or at least there's
a shot it won't be the case
we'll get some more of this in just one
second first
let us talk about the fact that if you
are a
good family person you want to make sure
that your family is protected one of the
ways you make sure your family is
protected
obviously is you own a firearm i'm a big
advocate of the second amendment your
rights and your freedoms are dependent
on the fact that you are able to defend
yourself and defend your family and
defend your community but here's the
problem
you see cases like this all the time in
the media where a good guy has to shoot
a bad guy and then
the good guy ends up in jail or the good
guy ends up getting picked up by the
cops
and grilled you need to know your rights
you need to know when you can and cannot
actually use
your firearm this is why you should
check out the uscca
right now the usca is providing to you
the complete concealed carry and family
defense guide
it is 100 free you will learn how to
detect attackers before they see you how
to survive a mass shooting the safest
and most dangerous places to sit in a
restaurant how to responsibly own and
store a gun
and a whole lot more it's a 164-page
guide complete with
valuable information just text ben to
87-222 to get involved with the uscca
get instant access and a chance to win a
thousand bucks so you can buy a gun to
protect your family text ben
to 87 222 right now to get involved with
the uscca again
text ben to 87 222 right now that's 87
222. okay so that that state action that
texas is taking
is an attempt to move beyond
what is the norm in terms of interstate
relations and to actually maximize the
power of the federal government to
control what happens within states this
is something republicans should not be
in favor of remember democrats
are openly proposing the rewriting of
the voting rights act
to allow federal pre-clearance of
gerrymandering and redistricting in
republican state
they want to take control from the top
down and now they wouldn't even have to
do that
via the legislature now they could just
do it through the supreme court
california
could say listen we have a certain
number of congress people because we
draw our districts properly
but you know down in georgia they don't
draw their districts properly and so we
are suing in the supreme court
saying that our congressional delegation
has been watered down
by the georgia congressional delegation
and therefore the supreme court is going
to have to re-gerrymander georgia is
this something you want
do you want the supreme court at the
behest of california re-gerrymandering
redistricting republican states
one of the great glories of the american
system is that you have delegated powers
actually honestly one of the guarantees
against widespread voter fraud and i
mean like national voter fraud is the
fact you do not have a centralized
voting system in the united states a
centralized voting system makes it more
likely not less likely that there's
going to be voter fraud
in fact inside states one of the best
guarantees against voter fraud and voter
regularity is the fact that the system
itself
is decentralized down to the county and
precinct level
and so again i can agree with with a lot
of the feelings
about how the election rules were done
in pennsylvania the pennsylvania supreme
court
for example randomly suggesting that you
can count ballots
after the day of the election is crazy
the the original decision by a
republican legislature in pennsylvania
to go along with universal mail and
balloting is idiotic
there are serious problems in these
electoral strategies and they do provide
for the possibility of fraud and it is
true
that democrats are pushing procedures
like getting rid of voter id in a
variety of states
that would make it easier to commit
voter fraud however to set up the
generalized legal principle which is
what
supreme court cases are about the
generalized legal principle that a state
can sue another state
for law applied inside that second state
that doesn't really affect the first
state directly
is just a disaster area it opens a can
of worms in serious
serious fashion well nonetheless about
106 republican
congress people have jumped into this by
the way i'm noticing that folks on the
left are suddenly respecting federalism
again again this is one of these
beautiful things that the left does so
the left hates federalism
as long as states rights mean that right
wingers actually control states
this means that states rights are really
bad they want nationalized rule from the
top the minute that they think they're
getting something out of federalism
suddenly federalism becomes good again
so federalism was really bad when jan
brewer governor of arizona started
enforcing immigration law
right at that point they were like you
know what the supreme court the the the
the federal government has supremacy the
supremacy law suggests that jan brewer
is not allowed to enforce immigration
law
on her own and then you have california
and california's like you know what
we're going to enforce
environmental law on our own and let's
like federalism
federalism is very good now california
should so
pay no attention to the ridiculous
spinning of the left because for the
left
institutions are merely an element of
power right they just grab power and
they use it whenever they can
and i understand the backlash of that on
the right which is okay fine so we'll
grab the institutions and we'll use the
power
when we have the power we won't worry
about the institution of neutral
principles
the problem is that it is much easier to
move
under the guys who've already
established neutral principles than it
is to violate
the neutral principles okay
institutional checks and balances and
institutional norms still do exist and
the more of those that are blown up the
easier it's going to be for future
people to grab
hold of sort of this empty area and then
use it in their own favor
so 106 house republicans have now signed
on to
this lawsuit according to yahoo.com
on tuesday texas attorney general by the
way not the solicitor general who would
normally be filing this sort of lawsuit
because he didn't like the lawsuit
texas attorney general filed a lawsuit
asking the supreme court to overturn the
election results in georgia michigan
pennsylvania and wisconsin
alleging that the state's improperly
manipulated voting rules 17 red states
have since filed in support of the suit
even though texas and several other
states
had implemented the same mail-in and
early voting rules by the same methods
in a further paradox 106
gop house members also joined texas's
suit as amicai curie despite the fact
many of them had been re-elected
on the same exact ballots in other words
they were coming from states they're
challenging the electoral methods used
in the same states where they were
elected which
obviously is sort of a weird oddity
not every congressional republican is on
board with the texas suit
senator ben sasse suggested that texas
attorney general was begging for a
pardon and filed a pr stunt
rather than a lawsuit and i'm not going
to suggest that's the case maybe it's
perfectly genuine
on the part of ken paxton who is the
texas a g i'm just saying that the
principle that would be established by
this
by by the case itself is not a
particularly good principle
okay what is irritating in the extreme
is again many things can be true at once
one can be that i think that this
lawsuit is badly predicated i think that
it sets a bad principle going forward
legally speaking
i think that if you were going to prove
voter fraud you do it the way that
georgia is talking about doing it you do
it the way that the georgia
gop is talking about doing it you file
actual suits that demonstrate actual
voter fraud
you bring evidence you bring names you
bring voter lists
you don't say i don't like the
procedures in that particular state that
is not my own state
and so you know what i'm filing a
lawsuit and directing it directly to the
supreme court like that's not the way
this should work truly it's not now that
can be true
it can also be true that there is real
suspicion in states
like georgia that irregularity happened
there is also
truth to the idea that the voting rules
in these states are garbage and that we
shouldn't have had
mass mail-in voting this year somehow
israel was able to carry out 97
elections in the last year
i mean really they have an election like
every 12 hours in israel now
um they were they cared about all that
in person effectively
and it was fine and it turns out that we
had mass voting
at the beginning of november and that
did not cause a mass spike in coveted
cases
so the the notion that we had to do
universal mail and balloting
is really really stupid and really
really silly all of that can be true it
can also be true that the media's
overwrought reaction to the texas
lawsuit
is irritating and stupid and that the
same people who are complaining about
the threat to democracy are fine with
threatening democracy when it suits
their purposes
and this is why nobody has any trust in
the other side you want to talk about
the country splitting apart there are
two ways that the country
could split apart one is that people
just keep
wrestling over the institutions of power
so as to cram down their own particular
view
on everybody else the other doesn't even
require that
the other is that there is such loss of
faith in the other side
that everybody assumes that everybody
has bad intentions which leads to the
first eventuality right if you believe
the other side has bad intentions
and they're going to grab the government
gun and point it at you you are more
likely to want to grab that gun first
right then it's a then it's a use the
government gun or be killed by the
government gun situation
and this is why so many republicans have
reacted to democrats
threatening democracy over and over and
over by saying okay well you know what
we don't really you know what
we're not going to be the ones standing
in the breach here
so it is somewhat irritating when we
hear all of these folks on the left
suddenly decrying
the challenges to elections and and and
the complaints about voter fraud and
voter irregularity and voting procedure
when literally two months ago this is
all they were talking about
donald trump and louis de joy the head
of the post office the postmaster
general you can remove mailboxes
donald trump is engaging in voter
suppression we had record voting this
year
by the way okay and then as soon as the
election's over oh no it's clean
how dare you challenge the election this
sort of gaslighting leads to the lack of
trust which leads to the belief
that people will game the system that
they will engage in voter fraud that
they will try to grab that government
gun
and use it against you and so when you
have mika brzezzinski
on msnbc saying people are dying while
they file this texas lawsuit i don't
remember mika brzezinski being quite so
upset
when people were literally dying as
there were mass protests in the streets
over the bullcrap notion that america's
systemically racist
this kind of gaslighting from the media
does have a real downstream effect on
how people think about the institutions
of government
and actually leads to the centralization
of government paradoxically instead of
people saying i disagree with you you
disagree with me so maybe the federal
government should be less powerful it
turns into
i disagree with you i suspect that you
are going to try to use the federal
government to cram down your viewpoint
on me
therefore let me grab the power of the
federal government and use that
to cram down my viewpoint on you okay so
here's mika brzezinski
yeah again this is just i would say
deeply irritating and annoying these are
trump's deaths
this is trump's virus it's not trump's
presidency anymore
and yet he continues to try and grab
onto it
in some pitiful or self-centered
effort to create a media empire
beyond his departure and exactly what is
that departure going to look like
is he going to hold on to the curtains
and be dragged out of there
while people are dying i don't even know
how to describe this behavior
it wouldn't be allowed in a
three-year-old child
uh come on i'm sorry the overwrought
trump is filing lawsuits and it's just
so terrible and how dare anybody follow
along
four years of russian collusion crap and
this is what you buy this is what you
buy
that doesn't mean that all of what's
been going on for the last several years
in terms of attacks on our institutions
is good but to pretend that it started
with trump or that trump is some sort of
break in kind from what has been
happening before is is quite silly
in fact i think the silliest element of
this was was you know exactly this sort
of historical ignorance
uh michael bischloss who is the uh nbc
historian
he he tweeted out yesterday that donald
trump keeps complaining about the press
and he's like lincoln never complained
about the press lincoln literally shut
down 300 newspapers and jailed people
who disagreed with him
so you've picked a poor example official
historian over
at nbc institutional distrust is growing
it's growing because we don't trust each
other and we don't trust each other
mainly because one side of the political
aisle decided a very long time ago that
people on the other side of the
political aisle
were elementally evil and needed to be
curbed by the power of the federal
government
and the blowback you get is going to be
on the institutional level and it is bad
it is not good blowback
yeah i think that the institutions of
the united states ought to be preserved
if the right is attacking them i think
that's bad if the left is attacking them
i think that's bad
but i think that is a natural outgrowth
of an entire political strategy
militarized and weaponized by the left
to castigate one entire side of the
political aisle indeed the side of the
political owl that traditionally has
sided with declaration of independence
in the constitution
as racist sexist bigot homophobes who
need to be curbed by the power of the
federal government
okay in just a second we're going to be
getting to the biden team
because joe biden i get the feeling that
joe biden kind of just wants to sit
there like that's actually what he wants
his presidency to be is just him sitting
there
if he indeed he's elected president by
the electoral college december 14th
i have a feeling that joe biden really
just kind of wants to to
not do anything he wants like he's so
happy to be there because he's spending
his entire life trying to get there
that he is sort of cracking back against
the more radical members of his
coalition but i don't think he's going
to be able to hold back those tidewaters
we'll get to that in just one second
first let us talk
about the fact that if you are a an
american citizen you need to protect
yourself you need to protect your rights
you know i'm a huge believer
in the second amendment and this is why
i always say that owning a rifle is an
awesome responsibility building rifles
is no different that's why i'm impressed
with bravo company manufacturing the
people at bravo company mfg
support the right of responsible private
individuals to have the access and
ability to employ the same tools as
civilian law enforcement
as a means of defending ourselves our
loved ones our communities and our
freedoms should a threatening situation
ever arise
bcm assumes that when a rifle leaves
their shop it will be used in a life or
death situation by a responsible citizen
law enforcement officer or a soldier
overseas
quality is indeed of the utmost value to
them every component of a bcm rifle is
hand assembled
and tested by americans as an american
you have the luxury of living in a free
society where you can improve your life
through education
religious exploration and all of the
other sort of rights that you are
granted but
those are really protected by the second
amendment bcm knows that they know
that when you buy a gun the purpose is
generally not target shooting is to
protect yourself to learn more about
bravo company manufacturing head on over
to bravocompanymfg.com
you can discover more about their
products special offers upcoming news
that is bravocompanymfg.com if you need
it more convincing find out even more
about bcm and the awesome people who
make their products at youtube.com
bravo company usa alrighty in just one
second we're going to get to
joe biden supposedly attempting to hold
back those tidewaters and failing it
seems we'll get to that in one second
first
it is that glorious time of the week
when i give a shout out to a daily wire
member today
is kyle cushman of north carolina who
sent in this outstanding
triple threat tumbler shot to our
mailbag in the picture a smiling baby
boy is sitting on the couch
clearly thrilled by his family's latest
acquisitions
the message reads hey ben i recently got
two more leftist tears tumblers after
getting the all-access subscription
i thought you might enjoy this picture
of my very cute and squishy baby son
henry
surrounded by the best beverage vessels
the world has to offer indeed
that is the essence of parenting
excellence right there you're going to
be a great parent
you need to do exactly what just
happened in that picture thanks for the
picture congrats on that adorable
squishy baby
if you are not already a daily wear
member now is the time to join we've got
some amazing stuff right around
the corner we're adding the entire
prageru catalog to dailywear.com
candice owens is joining us at the daily
wire in nashville she's got her own
show we can't wait to bring it it's
something creative something new it's
going to be fantastic
also the michael moles show is now five
days a week adding more content
for our members to either enjoy or
ignore at their peril by the way
michael moles today i guess is
discussing the texas lawsuit i guess he
might take a slightly different point of
view than i do so give that a listen
we are also launching our first feature
film under daily wires upcoming
entertainment channel and
we are building a new investigative
journalism team to replace that
establishment media cartel so
head on outside the narrative come on
over to dailywire.com subscribe
you're going to want to join the fight
because that is the fight the fight for
the future is going to be whether
we allow the left to continue to take
over the culture because if they take
over the culture they're taking over
everything else
fight back by joining a daily wire
you're listening to the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast and radio
show in the nation
[Music]
meanwhile joe biden trying to hold back
the tidewaters here and uh
failing with regard to his own crowd so
i think that joe biden basically just
wants to sit around
that's basically his plan i mean he's
enjoyed it for the entire campaign why
not enjoy it into the future
he's building his entire team with
basically just his friends it's going to
be that 70s show he's just going to sit
in that basement smoking that bong and
passing it around with
like susan rice who he likes with dennis
mcdonough who he likes
he sort of picked a bunch of randos and
that are his friends and then he's like
you know i have a bunch of open
positions let's just pick lots to see
who exactly gets what open position so
somehow susan rice is going to end up
his domestic policy advisor now
recognize that she was the national
security adviser on obama so magically
she has more from a foreign policy
non-expert
to domestic policy not an expert so
that's excellent stuff
also he's choosing dennis mcdonough who
served as barack obama's chief of staff
as his secretary of veterans affairs
what well he's never served in uniform
he has no experience with the military
it doesn't matter
joe biden is so senile at this point
apparently that he's just like he's like
i have i have friends and and those
friends
dennis d have you ever met a man in the
military dennis have you
come on man you met person in the
military yeah you're you're secretary of
veterans
it sort of drifts off according to the
washington post however
the choices provided a fuller picture of
the type of government biden is building
one that relies heavily on officials who
have spent decades in public service and
has several historic firsts among the
nominations god the media are just
their tongues are so far okay we're i
mean it's just it's horrifying it's the
human centipede over here
but it's had less space for rising
democratic stars and representatives of
the party's
liberal wing this is prompting
opposition not just from republicans but
also from some of the democrats and
liberals
who kept biden united during the general
election campaign and here is where it's
going to break out into the open
prepare thyselves and so time magazine i
love this
time magazine decided on his person of
the year so
who should be the person in the air the
truth is the actual people of the year
should be big pharma right much maligned
big pharma that developed a vaccine
for covid inside of a year right which
is unbelievable like inside of nine
months they went from zero to one
hundred
and now hundreds of millions of doses of
vaccine for a contagious deadly disease
are going to be rolled out over the
course of the coming months
they didn't win it no the the people who
won it of course
were joe biden and commonwealth now it
is called the person of the year you may
have noticed right
person of the year person last i checked
with singular now i know that we
use singular and plural alternatively
these days i know that you are allowed
as a as an individual human
to say that your pronouns are they and
them
which is insane in and of itself but
apparently also person of the year now
means people of the year because they
didn't just feature joe biden on the
cover of time
they featured joe biden and kamala
harris kamala harris's only
accomplishment was getting her ass
so kicked during the primaries that she
dropped off before california could even
vote
and then being the right race and the
right gender those were her great
accomplishments in this race
really because if she were not black and
you're not a woman there is no way in
hell that your body would have selected
her
how do i know because he didn't select
amy kobach right he was actually in a
swing state
he overtly said that he was picking
somebody for her race doesn't matter
the the media are so excited about the
possibility of joe biden dying that
they're like you know what just stick
camelot and everything they're just
going to turn them into this two-headed
monster we're going to
like at no point was mike pence
featured as like a person of the year
with donald trump
the vice president is a warm bucket of
spit right that's the in the john adams
famous phrase
it's it's a useless office essentially
the vice presidency it's basically just
president in waiting
and the media can't wait man joe might
not get a food taster every time he's
with the media he ought to have that
food taster tasting his food
you can just see members of the media
just sitting in there in the room they
got a blow dart in the back
oh great kamal is president now
that's where this is going they cannot
wait putting camilleris on the cover of
time magazine as a person of the year
oh man they're so eager to get rid of
this guy they're so eager and they're
even more eager
because biden seems to still be in some
ways and institutionalize i say in some
ways because he's not overall
institutionalist
but he's making enemies among the
progressive left in his own party you
got to give credit where credit is due
when joe biden like joe biden said in
this
sort of stealth phone call that he was
doing with community activists and all
this he said in the phone call
a couple of things that are actually
worthy of note one he took the abigail
spanberger
a moderate congresswoman from virginia
democrat position that they shouldn't
defund the police because defund the
police is a phrase being used to beat up
democrats which obviously is true he
said we might lose that georgia senate
race if we keep saying that over and
over
right so joe biden cracking back against
the hard left inside his own
administration here was that from that
phone call
i also don't think we should get too far
ahead of ourselves
on dealing with police reform
in that because they've already labeled
us as being
defund the police anything we put
forward in terms of the organizational
structure
to change policing which i promise you
will occur
promise you just think to yourself and
give me advice whether we should do that
before january 5th because that's how
they beat the living hell out of us
across the country saying that we're
talking about defunding the police
we're not we're talking about holding
them accountable
okay so so biden is cracking back
against the left swing of his party
we'll see how well that goes for him but
more importantly he actually said
there's a bunch of stuff that i'm not
going to do via executive order right so
i'm not going to ban assault weapons
via executive order it's not something
that i'm going to do right because i
think that that's not constitutional now
i will note barack obama said the exact
same thing about deferred action for
childhood rivals he said it
dozens of times he said i don't have
unilateral power to suspend immigration
law then he went ahead and did it
because of course
democrats very often are into just
violating the institutional precepts
they already know
they don't want to abide by right they
say that they like those institutions
then if they have to break them then
they break them
okay but democrats are pushing biden
really hard on this stuff he is not
i have serious doubts that joe biden is
going to be the great bulwark here
according to the new york times today
joe biden is facing pressure from
congressional democrats to cancel
student loan debt on a vast scale
quickly and by executive action a
campaign that will be one of the first
tests of his relationship with the
liberal wing of his party
biden has endorsed cancelling ten
thousand dollars in federal student debt
per borrower through legislation
and insisted that chipping away at the
1.7 trillion dollars in loan debt held
by more than 43 million borrowers is
integral to his economic plan but
democratic leaders
backed by the party's left flank are
pressing for up to 50 grand of debt
relief per borrower executed
day one of his presidency more than 200
organizations of course including
the disreputable american federation of
teachers as well as the naacp
have joined the push there are a lot of
people who came out to vote in this
election who frankly did their last shot
at seeing whether the government can
really work for them said representative
pamila jayapal democrat of washington
chairwoman
of the congressional progressive caucus
if we don't deliver quick relief it's
going to be very difficult to get them
back
so joe biden has said that he does not
want to do this he wants to do this
through legislation now
this is why i think that secretly if
you're joe biden you got to be praying
that the democrats lose the georgia
senate races
seriously because then you get to claim
that you were doing your best but you
didn't get anything done
the economy does really well because you
can't wreck the economy with a
democratic majority in the senate
pushing a bunch of stupid crap
and then you get to claim that you to
your progressive base you're doing the
best you could but mitch mcconnell was
standing in the way
and also you get all the benefits of
republican governance with none of the
cost
and like if you're joe biden that's what
you're hoping for i don't think that he
is going to be that bullwork i don't
think that joe biden is going to be the
bulwark of normalcy and institutional
fealty
i i think the chances that if democrats
were to gain the senate and georgia they
nuked the filibuster are 100
which is why republicans should go out
and they should vote in georgia on mass
and by the way the data suggests that
that's what republicans are doing
they're not being dissuaded by lynn wood
and other grifters i mean that is a
grift move okay as soon as you say
that you should not vote for republicans
in a georgia senate election and let
raphael warnock become a member of the
senate because you're angry
about georgia's election procedures
you've now joined a grift okay that is a
that is a grift move
i understand that people are angry i get
it i do
but that does not mean that you simply
cede the seat to a to a radical democrat
marxist that's a that's a nutty a nutty
idea
but it's why republicans need to hold
the senate if you're joe biden
honestly your your best shot at life may
be a republican senate
but joe biden is not going to be the guy
who who stands for institutional
normalcy for long i have serious doubts
that he is going to be
exactly the sort of bulwark that he
claims that he is going to be
now meanwhile the hunter biden story
continues to
move forward that hunter biden's story
is finally being you're allowed to cover
it now that's exciting stuff isn't that
fun
so the new york times says investigation
of joe biden's son is likely to hang
over biden as he takes office
why wouldn't it have been nice if the
investigation of joe biden's son
had actually been covered you know
before the election wouldn't that have
been a nice good thing
well now the new york times is covering
it because the election's over again as
i pointed out yesterday
your media are just the pr wing for the
democratic party now it is safe to talk
about the fact that hunter biden is
corrupt as the day is long
and was trafficking in daddy's name and
everybody knew about this for years
including joe biden
now we can talk about it so the new york
times says the newly disclosed federal
tax investigation into his son
will test president-elect joseph r
biden's stated commitment to independent
law enforcement while leaving him in a
no-win situation
that could prove distracting at best and
politically and legally perilous at
worst
unless president trump's justice
department clears hunter biden of
wrongdoing before leaving office
the new president will confront the
prospect of his own newly installed
administration deciding
how or whether to proceed with an
inquiry that could expose his son to
criminal prosecution
already some republicans are demanding a
special counsel be appointed to insulate
the case from political influence which
would be the gift that keeps on giving i
have a feeling that that will happen
before the end of the trump
administration if indeed it comes to an
end on january 20th
i have a feeling that a special counsel
will be appointed so that joe biden
can't simply come in
and quash the case against his son and
by the way anybody who suspects that joe
biden wouldn't do that that he is just
he
he's so institutionally loyal that he'd
be like yeah just go ahead with your
prosecution there uh of hunter
i'm sure that's exactly what would
happen with joe biden
on the campaign trail meanwhile biden
excoriated trump's efforts to use the
fbi and doj to go after his enemies
but the reality is of course that it is
the the fbi and the doj acted
independently of trump so much so that
the doj did not announce the
investigation
until now right the doj had suggested it
was a covert
it was a covert investigation which is
kind of crazy considering that there was
already news of this investigation
floating around in october
right there are rumors that this
investigation was floating around in
october and the fbi and doj just refused
to confirm it
because they didn't want to get involved
in the election which is crazy because
that's called getting involved in the
election
but in any case the fbi and doj are
indeed
investigating hunter biden and now we
are allowed to cover it meanwhile
team biden is running from this so jill
biden was asked specifically about
hunter biden
and the reporter who asked was
immediately shoot out of the room the
other day
are you talking to him one thing on the
next
reaction to the news of the
investigation of yours
catch you later everybody see you later
now remember
it was donald trump who's the threat to
the freedom of the press but ask a
question of joe biden and you will
immediately
be ushered outside of the room if you
are a reporter
also quick flashback here remember how
the media covered this thing in the
first place
remember when christian amanpour
suggested there was literally no
evidence of hunter biden's corruption on
cnn
very trusted journalists over at cnn
this is solid stuff
you're okay with our interests being
sailed out to profit
uh joe biden and his family when when
we're suffering during a pandemic from
communist china
okay as as you know perfectly well i'm a
journalist and a reporter and i follow
the facts
and there has never been any issues in
terms of corruption now let me ask you
this
yesterday the fbi fbi i
know that i'm talking about reporting
and any evidence reporting in any
evidence oh yeah it turns out that he's
been under federal investigation
uh since 2018 which is why it is so rich
i just have to point out our esteemed
journalistic colleagues over at cnn it
is so
rich and wonderful that kate baldwin
of cnn and one of their anchors
she put on a sweater on air thursday
it said on it in pink writing facts
first
because now we are just in the position
of posturing journalists are in the
position of posturing as though this is
what they do if you have to say
that as a journalist you're facts first
that means that everybody suspects that
you're not
it also happens to be particularly rich
not just that you wore this obnoxious
sweater which is a sweater designed to
say
i am better than you it's really a
sweater designed to alienate everybody
but also that this was immediately
put online for sale by lingua franca for
so if you too wish to mirror the
journalistic priorities of cnn
then you can buy a 380 sweater
in the middle of an economic downturn
and a pandemic
so that you can look like kate baldwin
on cnn
talking about facts first on a network
that routinely ignore fact
solid stuff right there and then they uh
they they put up
did lingua franca a little poem so it
was like a haiku of stupidity
over at lingua franca said smoke with
true red embroidery 100 cashmere
hand-stitched
in new york city facts are fact they
aren't colored by emotion or bias they
are indisputable
there is an alternative to a fact facts
explain things
what they are how they happen facts are
not interpretations
once facts are established opinions can
be formed and while opinions matter they
don't change facts
we stand with our friends at cnn who
start with the facts
first also you're gonna need to allow
two to three weeks for the embroidery
plus shipping time one to three days
380 so that you two can look like a
reporter on a garbage news network that
promulgates opinion as fact and then
pretends that they're facts first
my goodness cnn what a mockery they are
and what a mockery they continue to be
systemic trust in the media distrust in
the media continues to be at all-time
highs
as well it should be okay now i i would
be remiss if i did not mention that
there is some good news
in the country the nih director
announced that americans may start
receiving vaccinations on monday for
covet 19 the fda is supposed to approve
this thing
over the weekend the the tranching is
supposed to start with people in nursing
homes as it should
it's also going to start with frontline
healthcare workers as it should because
you don't want healthcare workers in
hospitals getting infected and then
infecting other people
in the hospital who do not have the who
do not have corona virus
this should be trenched out according to
health condition right should start with
people not not even by age but by
pre-existing health condition
and then trench out over the course of
the next few months this is all
happening under the trump administration
joe biden deserves zero credit for this
zero zero zero and watch the media will
try to provide him with credit
as though he's come up with a plan here
at no point has biden or anybody else in
the democratic party come up with a plan
here this is this is a trump
administration
master stroke operation war of speed
trump deserves every single bit of
credit here
democrats deserve essentially none i
mean this is this is
this is the president's largest
initiative
it is it is the most powerful scientific
initiative undertaken by the united
states
in all likelihood in history the only
thing that could possibly mirror it is
attempting to land a man on the moon
but but it is it is amazing stuff here
is the national institutes of health
director announcing that americans may
start their vaccinations on monday
when you say very soon and very soon do
you mean you know today's thursday do
you mean we might see shots injected on
monday is that reasonable it's
it's entirely possible i don't want to
preempt the fda
they're going to need to look at the
comments that were made today by this
advisory committee but i think it's
quite reasonable
okay meanwhile how are the media
covering this well msnbc was having on
an analyst to suggest that the gop is
using kova to kill people
this guy here he was the real blame here
is mitch mcconnell is the republicans as
the president is a party that does
not want to help people that is working
on one side
to actually make sure the pandemic kills
as many people as possible that seems to
be the logical consequence of their
policy
and then to make sure that all the
people who manage to survive it
despite their policy suffer economically
and beyond
solid analysis there from anand girard
haradas who is a commentator for
msnbc that their goal is to kill as many
people as possible
really really good stuff which is
presumably why the trump administration
has developed the vast the fastest
vaccine
in the history of humanity and hundreds
of millions of doses will be
put out there within the next couple of
months by the way speaking
of news that the media largely
downplayed yet another peace deal was
signed in the middle east yesterday
full normalization of relations between
israel and morocco this makes the fourth
country to sign normalization of
relations
with israel over the course of the last
six months alone
according to the wall street journal
israel and morocco agreed to normalize
relations president trump and israeli
prime minister netanyahu said thursday
marking another advance in u.s efforts
to strengthen ties between once hostile
nations in the region this is the wall
street journal reporting the us brokered
deal
was the fourth in four months between
israel and arab countries that have
refused to recognize the nation since it
was created
in 1948. netanyahu said this will be a
very warm piece adding that israel and
morocco would quickly set up liaison
offices
and introduce direct flights between the
two countries
a moroccan official didn't comment on
any agreement to recognize israel while
welcoming
trump's declaration of robots
sovereignty over western sahara which is
a departure from decades-long u.s policy
basically western sahara
is a giant desert there are about 600
000 people who live in the entirety
of the western sahara it's been under
dispute for decades morocco has had
effective control of it the united
states
sort of recognizes morocco's sovereignty
over that area
and meanwhile morocco signs a peace deal
with israel
okay the the entire biden foreign policy
makes no sense it continues to make no
sense
if there were any justice in the world
trump would win the nobel peace prize he
has made four separate deals in the
middle east
in an area where no one could make a
deal other than america surrendering to
iran over the course of the last 20.
it's an amazing accomplishment naturally
the media make kamala harris the person
of the year along with joe biden
for being a human on the cover of time
magazine
alrighty so just to finish this week i
thought that i'd bring back a little bit
of
bible talk because you know i think that
there's some important things to be
learned from the world's most important
document it is
by numbers the world's most important
document also fun statistic
the number one most stolen book on
planet earth is the bible which sort of
defeats the purpose in any case uh the
the portion of the bible that the jews
read this week is the portion
discussing the the joseph story the
beginning of the joseph story anyway
you'll remember that joseph is the son
of jacob jacob has 12 sons
and joseph is tossed in a pit by his
brothers this is the subject of the
musical joseph and the technicolor
dreamcoat
right that's the uh so joseph gets
tossed in a pit he's eventually sold
to a band of traveling midianites he
ends up in egypt
where he ends up in jail eventually and
then ends up becoming essentially second
in command
to pharaoh after which he reunites with
his brothers that's sort of the short
form
of that particular story but there's
another story embedded in the joseph
story that's kind of important the
reason it's important
is is because it discusses the one of
the other brothers
so to understand why this brother is
important you have to understand that in
subsequent jewish history
the kingdom of israel gets divided if
you read the uh
the tanakh or in hebrew or the the
writings and the prophets
in in english what you see is in
subsequent jewish history
after king david there's king solomon
then after king solomon the kingdom
starts
getting divided right king solomon has a
son there's a rebellion against his son
and eventually the kingdom of israel
splits up into the kingdom of israel and
the kingdom of
judah right this is why jews are called
jews right it's after judah
right they're not called israelites
they're called jews okay so who
is judah right who is yehudah in in the
bible
right who is again in in hebrew jews are
called
so judah is obviously a pretty seminal
character
so who is he in the bible and what makes
him special what distinguishes him
from his brothers after all he was the
fourth son of leia
he's not the firstborn he's not the
oldest he's not even the firstborn among
the children of his mother because jacob
has four wives
to produce children right he has two
handmaids and then he also has two wives
in any case
judah does not look like the guy who is
going to be the leader right maybe
joseph will be the leader he's the most
clever
maybe reuben will be the leader because
he's the firstborn instead it ends up
being judah and to understand
why that is we have to understand one
specific quality of leadership that
judah has
and that makes it possible for the tribe
of judah to sort of be the leading tribe
because the idea
in jewish thought and also in christian
thought is that the leadership of israel
will come from the tribe of
judah okay so the story of judah begins
basically
when judah decides that he is going to
prevent
joseph from dying by selling him into
slavery so what happens that joseph has
all of these dreams
and the dreams seem to suggest that he
is going to predominate over his
brothers and his brother's like this is
a threat to us
our father prefers joseph over us we're
afraid that joseph is going to take
revenge on us
and so let's let's kill him and so there
are two ideas that are put forth one is
put forth by reuben who's the firstborn
and ruben's idea is we are going to
reuven
his idea is that we are going to throw
him in a pit i'm going to come back
later i'm going to get him out
right we're not going to kill him we're
not like he doesn't say this to his
brothers
he has this idea that he's going to save
his brother joseph from anything bad
happening to him
so instead of just killing him out right
we'll throw him in a pit that way we're
not directly responsible for his death
if he dies in the pit he dies in the pit
what can we have done
and uh and then i'll come back later and
i'll get him out of the pit judah
instead says okay what we're going to do
is we are going to
throw him in the pit but then he says
what is the gain if we slay our brother
and cover up
his blood come let us sell him to the
ishmael ishmaelites but our hand shall
not be upon him for he is our brother
our flesh so the the the idea is that
we're not going to kill him
at all we'll sell him into slavery okay
and reuben comes back
joseph's been sold and reuben starts
mourning
and he says the boy is gone and where
will i go right i'm responsible what's
going to happen to me and so they all
decide that because they're afraid that
reuben is gonna bear the consequences of
of joseph being sold into slavery uh
that they are going to cover this thing
up and they they take the
dream coat the the technicolor dreamcoat
and they put blood on it and then they
go back to jacob and they say
our your brother got killed and jacob
goes into mourning so that is the first
instance that we see of judah is that
judah is trying to deflect
direct blame from his brothers by
suggesting that they sell
they sell joseph into slavery okay the
second thing
that we see about judah is this really
weird story
about his daughter-in-law so judah like
a little bit later like right after this
in the bible
it says at about that time the judah was
demoted by his brothers
that he was now looked upon and scorned
by his brothers like his brothers were
angry at him for having done
all of this so he turned away and he
came to an adolemite man named hira
and judah saw the daughter of a merchant
named shua he took her and he had a
couple of kids
and then one of his kids marries a woman
named tamar
okay and that kid dies tamar marries the
brother this is
combination practice tamar marries the
brother that second brother
dies at this point there's another
brother
and judah says you know what we're i i
don't want him
to marry the youngest brother right
because
she obviously is kind of a black widow
here and whatever happened to the first
two brothers will likely happen to the
third brother i don't want all my kids
dead
tamar realizes that he has what is
called the leverite obligation
and so actually judah somebody from the
family has to marry her so it ought to
be judah
so in this really bizarre situation she
dresses up as a prostitute on the side
of the road
and she has sex with judah who doesn't
recognize her and
she conceives by him and then later she
comes and he hears that she's pregnant
and people come to him he's like okay
well ancient times death penalty for
this sort of thing
uh and they bring tamar to him and she
instead of saying you know this is your
kid
she instead presents his signet ring to
him which had given her his payment
and he instead of going ahead with the
ruse he says she's right
the child is from me because i did not
give her to my son
and then she ends up having kids so what
is the point of this sidetrack of the
story right it literally has nothing to
do with the rest of the story like we
don't know what it has to do with joseph
it breaks up the narrative
what exactly is going on here the answer
is that is that judah
after creating a whole narrative about
joseph just so he did not have to take
responsibility and reuben didn't have to
take responsibility and no one would
have to take responsibility
judah changes something happens to judah
and suddenly
he starts taking responsibility for
things that are happening right suddenly
he's presented like an amazing
opportunity to completely
abdicate responsibility got a woman here
she's three months pregnant he
impregnated her
she does not actually name him as the
father and he could just say okay take
her out
and be done with her and instead he says
nope that's my kid
i've sinned here it's my fault and the
kid is legitimate obviously
and uh and this ends up being the seat
of the davidic line right doesn't the
event line doesn't end up getting
started in a very honorable fashion it
gets started
by the daughter-in-law of a man who's
supposed to marry her acting like a
prostitute literally on the side of a
road
in order to get pregnant by him right
that is that is not
the way that you would if you were going
to write the history of your nation this
is typically not the way
you start writing the history of the
most prestigious dynasty in your nation
is with this
and and judaism is filled with this sort
of stuff which is one of the reasons i
love it is because
judaism and old testament religion is
filled with these very
shaded and contradictory and human
stories of people
it is not about whitewashing the past
it's about acknowledging the sins of the
past and recognizing that out of those
sins very often comes something good
but the thing about judah that is unique
here is again the fact that he accepts
responsibility for the bad things that
he has done and this becomes the common
pattern with judah
to the point that when later in the
story he faces joseph right he comes
down to egypt now joseph
is the second in command to to pharaoh
and judah comes down
and joseph is attempting to see if his
brothers have learned anything from
what they did to him a long time ago and
he says i want you to bring your
youngest brother benjamin who is
who is joseph's full brother right all
these others are his half brothers
and he says i want you to bring benjamin
here i want to imprison benjamin
and judah instead says take me instead
he says the same thing to jacob
right to get jacob to let them send
benjamin he says you know what i'll put
my life
on the line right reuben says i'll take
my sons and you can take my sons instead
he says that's jacob something happens
to benjamin then you can do something to
my sons but judah's like you know what
no
you can do something to me he says i
will take the full responsibility he
says send the lad with me
we'll get up and go we'll live and not
die both you and also our young children
i will guarantee him from my hand you
can demand him if i do not bring him to
you and stand him up before you
i will have sinned against you forever
and this becomes the common theme for
judah judah is always the guy who takes
responsibility so
what do we learn about this from
leadership the one quality we know above
all about judah
is that judah takes the hit judah takes
the blame
judah is willing to accept the
responsibility because accepting the
credit is easy
that's the easy part accepting the
responsibility is the tough part and
that's something to remember when we
select our leaders
so here's the bottom line when you live
in a democracy and you select your
leaders it's up to you to determine what
qualities you're looking for one of the
top qualities you should be looking for
as harry truman once said is the buck
stops here if your leaders are not
willing to say that the buck stops with
them
and if it appears they are trying to
always escape responsibility by blaming
somebody else or blaming the american
public or blaming something else
well then that person probably should
not be the leader alrighty
now if you want to hear a different take
on the texas lawsuit than the one you
heard on
this show head on over to michael
knowles show right now he's talking
about it and then later today
andrew clavin will be guest hosting two
additional hours of my show the ben
shapiro show so
make sure to tune in for that have a
wonderful hanukkah if you celebrate it
otherwise we'll see you here
next week i'm ben shapiro this is the
ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas executive producer jeremy
boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
production manager pavel wiedowsky our
associate producers are rebecca doyle
and savannah dominguez the show is
edited by adam's high events
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by fabiola christina
production assistant jessica kranz
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright 2020.
you know the matt wall show it's not
just another show about about politics i
think there are enough of those
already out there we talk about culture
because culture drives
politics and it drives everything else
so my main focuses are
life family faith those are fundamental
and that's what this show is about hope
you'll give it a listen